hi have you have you heard about AI
lately maybe like
a little bit cool
um so yeah so reading all the the
breathless hype around AI it's really
easy to lose sight of the fact that it
isn't Magic pixie dust you just sprinkle
on top of a problem and solution pops
out
does this work did that do the thing
this doesn't work either
how about that hey okay I'm gonna be
double fisting the laptops
here's here's how we're going to do this
um
in fact the idea that an average team
would think about adding AI to a product
was nonsense like two years ago and Once
Upon a Time all machine learning was
very handcrafted like artisanal every
application required that a bunch of
phds with deep domain expertise uh build
an algorithm that was single purpose and
one purpose only and it wouldn't
generalize the number of people who
could do this was vanishingly small and
when I think about what's happened in
the last two years what strikes me is
how many more people are using far fewer
tools to add intelligence to their
products and actually we've seen uh two
revolutions in the space happen in the
last decade right the first was the
Advent of deep learning right my my
better half my wife happens to be a
machine learning engineer and she spent
a good chunk of her career working on
algorithms for medical computer vision
I remember when she came home from a
conference and told me how every
Benchmark in the field was being
absolutely destroyed by this single
technique deep learning uh tens of
percent of improvement using a
generalized technique where people were
normally happy to squeeze out like one
to two percent like Improvement would
have been like whoa a really high water
mark for like you know submitting a
paper to a conference
um
uh so machine learning uh after deep
learning is still difficult but now
there's only one technique and many more
people who know how to wield it many
more sources of information about how to
use that one technique to uh uh uh to
build things how to get other people up
to speed right like lots more blog posts
and things to read and learn and the
second uh uh sort of uh Revolution was
the broad availability of large language
models right now you needed no
particular skills to use machine
learning uh you take a generalized
off-the-shelf model and you prompt it in
plain English and Magic happens so
basically
um uh any school child has like all the
tools they need for talking to this
thing so now we have one tool that seems
to be pretty great at a lot of tasks and
you don't really even need to write code
to use it
um uh uh so in reality this picture
tells me that we've just moved the
problem domain around it's ridiculously
easy to grab an API key and come up with
a naive prompt and build a little demo
that works some of the time and that's
exactly what's driving a lot of this
hype because 10 minutes after you get
your API key you have something you can
screenshot and tweet and share and go
ask a venture capitalist to fund so
um
yeah but demos are not products it's
really easy to cherry pick results that
look amazing uh except that all of that
falls apart as soon as you have a
product that people use right you have
to make it robust you have to make it
deliver value to a wide variety of
people uh from different backgrounds you
have to come up with a notion of what
constitutes good right versus bad and
you have to come up with a way to
measure your thing to know if the effort
you're putting in to improve it is
taking you in the right direction
and if you're trying to add intelligence
to an existing product then you're
probably going to want to change how
that product works in order to make the
AI Parts exceed
when televisions were first invented the
dominant form of broadcast entertainment
was the radio drama right the first
television shows were just radio dramas
with a camera like they just stick a
camera in front of the people that were
there with like all these props that
made noises like they pop a balloon and
it's like bang like a gunshot and that's
when the murder happened or whatever
they didn't yet know the language of
this new medium they didn't know how to
make television they knew how to make
radio and they just stuck a camera in
front of it and
um You probably don't want to make
things like that and that's kind of
where we are today with uh AI
so uh hi
my name is Edon today I want to talk a
little bit about the things that go into
making products
um I lead a prototyping team at GitHub
called get up next uh you may have heard
of us we have done things like copilot
which you may have used
um a little over two years ago when we
were first starting work on the thing
that eventually became co-pilot there
was almost no prior art we had to figure
everything out how it should look and
how it should work and how we test and
measure so that we could iterate
and fast forward to like last week there
was a big get a marketing launch thing
copilot X whatever it's really six
different things in like a trench coat
it's no longer one modality it's no
longer just in the editor and it's no
longer just about writing code it could
be about writing tests or explaining
your PRS or putting a more helpful
interface on top of your documentation
but the bottom line Remains the Same
and that is that every product needs a
mountain of work to earn its launch and
it's not the same Mountain that we might
be used to climbing the mountain is
often work that has nothing at all to do
with AI
so prototypes are your base camp let's
talk about this mountain this the rest
of this talk is all about this mountain
of work and what's hiding inside it and
what it takes to go from That Base Camp
to The Summit
so let's start with the user experience
of AI
if I showed you this text you know 30
years ago this blue underlined text it
had no particular meaning but by now it
has a fairly universal meaning right I
can show this text to anybody and be
like yep that's that's a hyperlink I can
go where it links by clicking or tapping
on it and at some point in the late 90s
earlier that meaning became general
knowledge it became a basic mechanism in
the sense of like a pulley or a screw or
a lever these fundamental mechanical
things that we've discovered out of
which larger machines are composed
um uh ultimately
these basic mechanisms afford you some
mechanical advantage you're doing the
same work but that work is easier so the
hyperlink was one of the first simple
machines discovered in the internet age
right instead of manually needing to
like take an address and type it I could
just click on the thing and and go there
and every time we find a new
technological medium we discover new
basic mechanisms for it even today like
you know as soon as the smartphone was
invented when they were first invented
refreshing content was like I had to
find the refresh button and top it which
was fine I mean I have a button and I
tap it but it's taking up screen real
estate uh it wasn't until 2008 when
Tweety the original Twitter app that
later got bought by Twitter and turned
into the Twitter app
um first implemented pull to refresh and
as soon as that happened that was very
clearly like oh that's that's real
television that's not radio dramas for
iPhones
um because it banked on everybody's
implicit understanding that new content
is further up right and it didn't take
long for like all the smartphone
platforms to adopt this mechanism as a
native gesture
so now we have ai and there will
definitely be new basic mechanisms uh
and I count three so far that we've sort
of come across
um there is Ghost text for any kind of
creative activity
um and I would argue that ghost text is
designed for optionality giving me a lot
of different options
um there is brushes which are designed
for editing and I'd say that they're
just their uh purpose is transformation
I want to take something and I want to
apply some kind of transformation to it
and then there's chat everybody knows
and loves chat now it's really you know
the Zoolander meme have you heard about
chat so hot right now
um uh I would say the chat is about
exploration and planning right designing
for iteration and that sort of modality
of of interaction
um two years ago chat and brushes didn't
exist and we were focused on the basic
problem of how to present code
suggestions to users and ghost text
wasn't actually the first thing that we
tried the first thing that we tried was
generating a list of potential
suggestions to accept and this by the
way little known fact if you like
control enter you will get this
interface and copilot today it's still
there even though almost nobody uses it
and I get why because it's not as
helpful it surfaces a lot of options and
it's particularly helpful in contexts
where you don't quite know how to do a
thing because each suggestion might show
you a different way to do that thing or
maybe like you'll see like oh I want
like a little bit of that part but then
I also want to follow it up with like
that approach from suggestion number
three but on the flip side you're
incurring a lot more compute cost to
eagerly generate suggestions number two
through ten which most people never go
to just like the second page of Google
and uh and it's modal right you you to
use this you have to stop typing invoke
copilot wait and then browse the options
and then that's a tax on your executive
function to like choose among them like
you know which one of these do I want
which is a higher executive function tax
than
um yes or no right
um and if you don't like any of the
options then you have to like back out
alter your code and repeat this process
so you pay this tax over and over again
one of the other prototypes that ended
up in The Cutting Room floor was like a
Tinder style accept or reject right and
this definitely had the benefit of
lowering uh costs like actual dollar
costs because we're not generating 10
things at once we're running inference
to generate just one
um but it was still unacceptably modal
like you needed to stop the activity of
coding trigger copilot and then take
another positive action to move forward
and that's a lot of disruption for a
developer that's in the flow of creation
and we really didn't want to sacrifice
that
um and so we ended up with ghost text
right we didn't invent this mechanism
I'm pretty sure that there were Snippets
of ghost text in Gmail by that point
um but they were like a few words at
most like hi nice to meet you or like
you know thanks and keep in touch or
something of that sort of order and that
was definitely the right call uh uh
ghost text for co-pilot for a few
reasons first it's ignorable
um which sounds bad especially for like
a product it's like I want my product to
be ignorable
um no uh it's ignorable and that's good
and it's modeless I'm not switching into
a different mode while working with it
you can wait for them to appear or you
can keep typing and if you do wait for
them to appear you can decide if you
like or don't like them and keep typing
there's no like additional action that's
forced on you as somebody who's like in
the flow of typing
and if you you kind of like the
suggestion
but maybe like you think that if you
give it a little bit more context you're
likely to get a better one then you can
just keep typing a couple more
characters and get a new suggestion
right there again without having to
toggle back and forth between these
modes
and finally being modeless reduces the
friction to accept and edit meaning if I
like part of a suggestion or like it's
like okay I see where you're going with
this I don't want exactly that but
you've shown me the way and now I want
to take that and adopt it for my
purposes
then I can do that very easily with
ghost text I accept and I can
immediately I'm still there with my
cursor in the editor right there at the
end of the suggestion I can go back and
edit it so it's not demanding too much
commitment from me as a user
um there's one very key downside to
ghost text and that it's uh it's ghost
ghostly ghosted it's ghost text whatever
uh without the assistance of syntax
highlighting um it's harder for me to
read the suggestion I mean I've gotten
accustomed to all the code that I read
being syntax highlighted and I'm sure
everybody else has as well
um uh the problem is is that you can't
control for users themes like some some
psychopath out there has like some Wild
theme with like crazy colors and if you
reduce it to 50 opacity then some of
those colors are going to be illegible
and so we can't ghost text syntax
highlighted things
um so that sucks but it's a reasonable
trade-off for all these other good
qualities that I highlighted
uh but most critically ghost text is a
kind of hedge against suggestion quality
not being where we want it to be like we
might not be far off from a future where
most suggestions are bang on but today
it's not yet the case like we need to
design for the failure mode where we are
today where the AI isn't perfect and not
all the suggestions are exactly what I
want like we still haven't developed
like
you know telepathy brain link whatever
like Elon Musk is supposedly cooking up
I don't know
um uh suggestions can be wrong they can
be distracting
um uh I might not want them right now if
you don't make your ux forgiving then on
some level you're betting and your
ability to get perfect results out of
the model and if you don't have that
ability you need to design against it
and sometimes it's fine but for lots of
applications you can't assume that level
of reliability and quality
um
something interesting that I've noticed
about the ux of ghost text I don't
really have an answer for this it's
really just something I'd like to note
is that it's slowly changing the way
that I type while coding like over time
I've gotten a sense for when it's likely
to deliver a good suggestion and whatnot
like if I'm working in a file where I've
already supplied a lot of context and
I'm doing something that feels
relatively boilerplaty or
straightforward then I'll slow down a
beat I'll I'll give the model a second
just to like flash me a suggestion
because maybe it'll home run it for me
and when I'm not like if I'm typing in
an empty file or I'm doing something not
obvious or I'm working on like basic
architecture when there isn't enough
information yet for the model to make
like uh like a sanguine guess about
where I'm going then I don't slow down
so something like you know there's
something in there about the feel of
like a gas and a break so the car that
you acquire over time through driving
there's something in there in the user
experience of ghost text and I think
it's really interesting that it's
changing literally how I physically
interact with the machine and I wonder
what more is out there like that
um
wait I'm going back I forgot one point
which is
um uh thinking about designing not for
the first use but for the hundredth or
thousandth time right like if you're
using copilot yeah on day one you're
like okay cool and by day like 30 you're
like I've seen this now literally a
billion times while coding
um so uh in addition to designing for uh
hedging against failures of the model
designing for the hundredth thousandth
millionth time that users are seeing a
thing and what is their experience going
to be in that study State not their
first impression which we often talk
about like one of the first impressions
of users how do we make sure that they
don't bounce right but uh we shouldn't
also neglect the other side of the
Spectrum which is like cool it was new
for five minutes and then you have the
rest of your life to like live with this
thing
okay
I have a little bit less to say about
the other two basic mechanics because
they're quite a bit younger brushes was
an experiment uh by one of my teammates
the very talented Amelia wattenberger
she is wattenberger on Twitter and you
should look her up because everything
she does is dope
um the ux of being able to paint
arbitrary Transformations onto code is
very powerful uh and super familiar to
anybody who's ever selected some text
and made it bold right
um except here you can select some text
and be like
um add comments or fix bugs or more
subtle instructions like make this more
accessible right you can actually sort
of uh Prime the model with these very
woolly instructions and actually get
useful results out of it so if ghostex
prioritizes the needs of uh creation
brushes is all about Transformations and
as much as we talk about writing code
maintenance is a much bigger part of the
job like you know I write code once but
then I maintain it forever so if we're
not designing interaction models for
that then we aren't designing
defensively for like the reality of our
jobs
if I had to make a guess I'd say that
we're going to see more interaction
models around
select manipulation of code maybe things
like brushes will be a jumping off point
for supplying context to other patterns
like chat like I select a thing and then
I apply some transformation but then it
shows up in my chat sidebar and I can
iterate on it before like you know like
now back to the studio Fred like and it
comes back to my my editor
speaking of chat
I'd argue that the core of chat is
iteration you can ask the model for
something and if it isn't quite right
you can refine and that refinement seems
like defensive design right like I'm I'm
guarding against
um like what if the model like didn't
quite hear me right and I just need to
sort of like can I say it again can I
say it louder
on one hand there's a ton of flexibility
right like you don't need to figure out
how to elicit desires from users because
they're just gonna tell you what they
want they're literally going to type it
into the box and that's fantastic but on
the flip side you might be dumping part
of the prompt crafting problem onto the
user and sort of abdicating your
responsibility as a maker of product
to help them succeed
that said
gpt35 was already pretty Adept at uh
interpreting requests and gpt4 is
clearly better in our experience so
maybe this isn't a problem anymore or
maybe it's not gonna be a meaningful
problem in the future
so I think the most interesting aspect
about chat is the statefulness of it the
Persistence of context
um but right now every conversation is
an island what happens in the future
when every conversation might be aware
of all previous conversations obviously
that's bounded by like what's the size
of your prompt window but maybe there
are other tricks that we can bring to
bear on that if I'm building chat into
my product I want to think maybe at this
point about how I'm making that history
useful to my users
so as basic mechanisms go I like these
three I think they cover the
um core set of behaviors and there's
enough wiggle room to handle messy cases
you might use chat to plan an alteration
or a brush to create a meaningful chunk
of new code so it's not like cut and dry
like use this for this and use that for
that use that for this other thing and
narrow the twain shall meet no they
actually do have some amount of like
gray overlap zone between them
some of your product considerations
won't be about modality they will be
about latency
everybody is excited for the power of
the latest models
um but with great power comes like very
slow responses so uh and they stream in
progressively which doesn't work for
some situations like not everything can
you like have the like like thing where
it shows up
um also the bigger newer models are not
always better very often you have to
make trade-offs of acceptable latency
versus model power like original copilot
does not like we did not upgrade it to
use gpt4 the reason being that is just
too slow like I can't get the full
response like if you imagine even just a
session with chat which is faster than
gpt4 if I waited for the full like
streaming response to show up say I
buffered all of that and I held it in
memory and then only when it was done
would I show that suggestion to the user
it effectively be waiting I don't know
like five ten seconds maybe depending on
the length of the response that I'm
expecting that's unacceptable I need to
be able to show like suggestions to
users in like 100 milliseconds or less
or I don't know whatever
um so
um part of the Mountain of work is
figuring out which models make sense to
use where it might be about latency or
it might be about cost like actual
dollar cost
um sometimes it's possible to invest
more energy into prompt crafting and
squeeze an acceptable level of results
from a cheaper model so there's like a
ton of levers that you can try pulling
around this but the answer of like which
model should I use oh the biggest and
most powerful and most expensive one is
not actually the correct answer in a lot
of cases
speaking about problem crafting I still
haven't touched on the elephant in the
room which is prompts on how to craft
them one of the largest rabbit holes uh
to get lost in are potential changes to
your underlying product in order to
elicit context from users that you can
then use for prompt crafting So like
um if I show you a to-do list
probably the point is not to give you a
to-do list there's a million to-do list
things out there and they're all fine
you know I have text with like check
boxes next to them
um but if you check a thing off you've
just told me about a semantically
meaningful event right I can use that to
trigger summarization of recent work and
create commits on your behalf I can
prime that summarization with a
description of the to do or I might want
to use that to instruct the model to
find the changes in your code base that
are relevant to that task because maybe
like you did a few different things but
then you remembered oh wait I took care
of this one and I took it off and then I
want to use that to do description to go
find the changes that belong in the next
commit or something like that
um
but this basically grows Your solution
space to Infinity like changing your
product is the bottomless Rabbit Hole of
options so yeah part of the Mountain of
work is figuring out like what's the
right trade-off how much do I think
about changing the product it's hard and
there's no really clear answers there so
I'm just telling you what's hard not
giving you really any useful Solutions
sometimes I like to joke uh that get up
next is the prompt whisper team that's
what we do we we whisper in the ear of
the Oracle oh wise Oracle please tell us
which set of characters comes next
um
it's a lot of trial and error right I
can't over emphasize this because the
models are famously black boxes right
like we don't know if any of you are
cryptography nerds
holler then it's kind of like a chosen
plain text attack on the like on the
models you're just constantly throwing
things at it and seeing what comes out
and then iterating on like what you're
throwing at the thing
um uh and whatever anecdotal thing you
try when you're designing your prompts
you don't know whether or not it works
uh just from your experience because
whatever you're seeing is at best
anecdotal so uh you need to do
measurement at scale and I'll talk about
that later
I want to invent maybe a distinction
that people like use prompt engineering
and prompt crafting interchangeably and
I kind of believe that they might
actually be two different things or that
they deserve to be two different things
prompt engineering is all of the work
needed to gather context and process it
and get it ready and prompt crafting is
more formulation like how am I
structuring the information that I have
on hand into my prompt so that I hand it
to the model
um
maybe somebody else has already coined
this and I'm late to this party whatever
um in naive olden days you know you'd
spend some time sourcing context and
then you just paste it wholesale into
the prompt then ship it right and
hopefully it's good enough but now we're
talking about all these fancier
architectures for the entire Pipeline
and you have heuristics at multiple
stages
so I'm going to talk mostly about prompt
engineering because prompt crafting is
like a topic for an entire talk and 15
different papers on archive so
um yeah
models only know how to say what comes
next asterisk this isn't strictly true
anymore but generally speaking that's
what models are right it's like you show
it something and you're like what comes
next
um and uh
they don't know how to say like what
goes in the middle
um so in the uh work of making copilot
like if the cursor is somewhere in the
middle of the file uh what if the code
that's further down is actually really
great context right what if the cursor
is at the start of the file like the
whole file comes after what context are
you supplying then right
um somebody once had a really nice
t-shirt or sticker that was like there's
no magic in the cloud there's no magic
in this it's just work
um so
um so like what do we need to do well
like we needed to like do all this crazy
work to hoist code around the file in
semantically sound fashion so we'd like
AST the entire code base build in
abstract syntax treat and then
restructure the code such that if like
you know the cursor is here and
um there's a function reference above
that's pointing to a function that's
further down I'm going to hoist that
function up above so that it is included
in the in the context because that seems
like it would be a useful bit of context
um but I've just described to you like
three months of work right how to do
that like properly correctly not mess it
up uh check it try it if any of you have
ever had the pleasure of using tree
sitter then you know exactly what I mean
um
so uh so uh yes oh did I not show the
hoisting okay well sorry you should have
been seeing this slide now
retrieval is another really interesting
technique that I think doesn't get
enough credit yet people are talking
about it like you know every once in a
while I see
an article and Hacker News about it but
um the basics of this technique are that
you use an uh a separate model to
generate embeddings vectors and high
dimensional like vector space
um to classify different parts of your
code and then you can use that as a kind
of similarity map like that indexing is
is very cheap you can run it all of the
time unlike fine tuning which is not
cheap and you have to do it if you want
uh your model to always be aware of like
latest developments and whatever you
need to do it basically all of the time
and particularly this has applications
for things like I would like to have
copilot that is very aware of our
private code base because the underlying
models are only trained on on public
sources right they don't know anything
about whatever you know
idiosyncrasies your corporate code base
has in it
um so how do we make copilot do a better
job of giving responses for those
situations that are like more in line
with whatever your company standards are
if we leaned on fine train on fine
tuning then we would need to train on
your code base and then train on it
again next week and then fine tune some
more at the week after and keep
fine-tuning forever and that kind of
cost is is just too high and also
everybody's in a knife fight for gpus so
maybe we don't even have the capacity to
pull that off
um but uh doing the embeddings and then
using that to find related code in order
to more effectively put useful context
in the prompt is way cheaper I can do
that all the time
um
uh and so the idea is basically like say
I'm editing some code to do with
authentication I could naively just
include the rest of the code in the file
in the prompt and send that off and be
like that's the context that's what I
got but uh we found that we've gotten
far better results from the models and
particularly the newer models that have
bigger prompt windows by saying you know
what I'm going to include not
necessarily the code that's in the same
file but I'm going to look for all other
code that deals with authentication
throughout the code base and I'm going
to use that as the prompt along with
specifically some amount of code from
the file that I'm in because you do need
to Anchor it somewhere
and that delivers actually fantastic
results
um
foreign
and this technique is particularly
relevant for the more powerful Models
All That prompt budget is not useful
unless it's actually used older models
have less prompt budget which forces a
lot of acrobatics for like prompt
crafting you know like we're sitting
around trying to come up with techniques
to like vote pieces of code off the
island so that we have enough like room
um so whichever model you use retrieval
can help if you have a lot of context
then great it helps you Source more of
that context if you have only a little
bit of context because you're using an
older model maybe it can help you like
choose like more wisely the context
that's going to give you the most bang
for your buck and squeeze better results
out of that cheaper model
Now for Something Completely Different
this is prompt crafting
um
this is a higher level idea that I
wanted to share on the prompt crafting
side uh everybody is aware of
um like one shot few shot for uh prompt
crafting this is fuchsia we experimented
a little bit with using llms to help
reduce toxicity and comments right like
how can we make everybody just a little
bit more civil to each other on on uh on
on GitHub because everybody knows you
roll up to like a project and maybe
there's somebody who's just like that's
a terrible idea and you're bad and you
should feel bad
but usually it includes a lot more
expletives so
um so we we tried this
um and uh one of the things that jumped
out of me is that the best uh strategy
that we had for prompting the model to
produce to reword how people uh uh uh
wrote their comments but in like a
better and nicer and Kinder way was to
reach for this notion of encode each
trait this high level hard to Define
thing like
um yeah I can be like I don't want
profanities in the code but I also want
um uh comments to be intellectually
curious how do you instruct a computer
to be intellectually curious I can't but
what I can do is be like okay here's a
formulation that isn't intellectually
curious and it's obvious to me because
you know I have so many years of my
brain learning what that means uh and
here's some uh text that is
intellectually curious and I can do that
over and over again for different traits
these high level things and so when you
think about like I would like all these
traits in the text that comes out you
can just think of examples of these
different traits and feed it to the
model and that actually tends to work
really well so give fuzzy examples with
this sort of strategy and we found that
it's delivered a lot of good results
it's looking like the state of the art
is already more than just call in
response to one model like yeah all of
the hot the hotness right now is all
about gpt4 and how good it is and how it
works in all these different modalities
and it really is a strong general
purpose model
um but uh retrieval which I just talked
about is already a conversation with
more than one model right I have an
embedding model and then I have the llm
copilot voice which if you haven't seen
is basically like Jarvis from Iron Man's
like I'm like typing and I'm like hey
copilot like run my test for me and also
like suggest this function here and also
like open my terminal and like I don't
know whatever it it works and it's kind
of cool but that's using different
models for different kinds of utterances
like I have like heuristics and models
figuring out is this utterance about the
terminal or is it about I would like to
open or hide some panel in the IDE or is
it about the code is it a question about
the code or am I instructing am I
dictating like give me a function that
looks up the weather in the ZIP code or
whatever
um and uh so multiple models is already
a technique that we're using and I think
that that's going to catch on like
wildfire in the coming years that
um there's only so much you can get out
of one model that you're just like
what's the answer that's the answer okay
that's it using multiple models uh
raises the ceiling of like what's
possible and looking further out we're
also seeing a lot of value in multiple
round trips to the model so for uh
example I'll round trip to be like
what's a list of files that I would need
in order to like implement this feature
right I want to add a new like route to
my a new capability to my website or my
web app or something like that and I'll
come back and be like here's a list of
files that I expect to see then and then
I'll take that and stuff it back in the
prompt and send it back to the server
and be like okay now what are the
contents of these files uh and I'll get
that and then I'll take all of that and
I'll shove it back into the prompt and
I'll be like now write me tests that
tests all the content in these files and
it's fantastically expensive and slow
from a computational perspective but one
day it won't be
um and I think that that's sort of like
that multiple round tripping sort of
action is already
um demonstrating some interesting
results
um but yeah bottom line is there's so
little prior art it's trivially easy to
spend a ton of time and energy uh on
this kind of trial and error and so uh
on to our third topic
which is measurement
how do we know that we're on the right
track how do we know if what we have is
good right
um
a huge huge chunk of the Mountain of
work is setting up automated evaluation
of your things like you change your
prompt crafting or you've changed which
model you're using or Which models
you're using
um how do you know if it's performing uh
well you can deploy it and see but you
probably want some kind of smoke test
before you you know throw your thing out
there and end up with egg on your face
if it's not working really well
um so in our case uh with copilot the
way that we uh build smoke tests is we
took code bases on GitHub that have a
test Suite already
we'd find functions that were tested and
we'd blank out the function bodies uh
ask copilot to generate those function
bodies and then run the test Suite right
uh and uh if we'd see like an uptick in
failures of those test weights then
whatever we're doing is clearly like
going in the wrong direction as opposed
to like if we see fewer failures then
clearly our strategy is paying off
um and
again this was a mountain of work to do
having nothing to do with AI we just
needed to like sit there and write this
whole like test harness just to have
like some kind of early warning light
about like are the changes that we're
making are they okay or are they
breaking something uh and it's
unglamorous and it's boring and it's
absolutely necessary
um like any product there's an explosion
of metrics to track
which ones matter right
um again drawing on our experience with
copilot we know what suggestions are
accepted or rejected right but even if
they are accepted it isn't binary like
it's good when people accept a
suggestion and then edit it we want that
behavior because we believe that that's
correct you know like take the
suggestion and adjust it to your needs
like it's fantastic if every suggestion
is just accepted wholesale and it works
perfectly right off the bat but we're
not there yet
um so we want to know about whether
they've like you know the users are
accepting suggestion and if they're
accepted how much of the suggestion
sticks around right so cool I have a
chart for acceptance rate and I have
another one tracking retention
percentage uh and I have that for like
30 seconds and one minute and five
minutes and 10 minutes after like you
know the code is suggested and accepted
or rejected or whatever
um and then we roll out an update to the
US so the prompt crafting or whatever
and so now I have however many of those
charts are times two because I've got
the old ones and the new ones and I
gotta compare them
um but wait maybe these metrics are
different by language okay hold on now I
need all those charts but for like
python Ruby C go rust whatever like in
all these different things and then
we'll see if like acceptance rates and
that'll tell me maybe like oh is the
model working better for that language
or for that language or is it just that
programmers in these languages just
don't lean on copilot as much or don't
need it or need it in fewer situations I
don't know
um uh and then
um you have practical considerations so
like maybe acceptance rates are about
latency like where is your inference
running if your answer is running in U.S
east or U.S West and then you have
developers in Asia or Europe and you're
seeing that their acceptance rates are
lower
is it really because something is bad or
is it just because it takes longer for
suggestions to show up for them because
the bits need to travel like across the
globe to get there in time
um what if uh like you know another 100
milliseconds of latency is why you're
seeing like a drop-off so you can see
this sort of like combinatoric explosion
of charts and part of the Mountain of
work is figuring out
the right amount of charts to keep an
eye on because you can't keep an eye on
like 100 charts at once you can't
possibly uh inform decision making with
that amount of stuff coming at your face
um and these charts encode a lot of
things that are hard to tease apart like
is it about the language is it about the
latency is it about this so you don't
want to drown yourself in metrics this
was true for products in general not
just for AI which I guess is a theme for
this talk
um but AI products are maybe a little
harder right now because there's less
conventional wisdom like I can open
Google right now and like type in how do
you measure a SAS product and get back
like Infinity blog posts that tell me
everything I need to know about it not
so much so for AI kind of things
I know I just said that metrics matter
and now I'm going to contradict myself
metrics are just a proxy for value at
the end of the day you need to figure
out what value is for your situation
like I'm obviously drawing on our
understanding of developers and what
developers want in their editors while
writing software as much as that is the
abroad activity it is also a relatively
narrow activity compared to all of the
other activities that exist out there
that people conduct with computers
um figuring out what value is for your
situation is the job keep figuring it
out it's a forever job it's a steady
state of workload forever and you need
to realize that you're signing yourself
up for that workload forever in fact
everything that I'm talking about today
sort of the underlying theme Here is
that when you want to do AI in your
products this is what you're signing
yourself up for whether you realize it
or not and so everybody who's made a
demo in five minutes and thinks that
they're halfway to a product then I got
bad news for you there's a lot more work
there's a lot more mountain left to
climb uh and if you're not stopping to
check whether or not you're delivering
value and that usually means sorry no
technology just talking to users and
understanding what it is that they find
valuable and understanding whether or
not the AI that you've added to their
lives is delivering value to them
then you're not doing your job
and you might be climbing the wrong
Mountain
thank you
[Music]